spotted Megan Markos stepping out for
the first time since mechs it as she's
reportedly set to face off against her
father in court the Duchess of Sussex
paid a surprise visit to the Downtown
Eastside Women's Center in Vancouver on
Tuesday the organization which provides
basic needs and positive change for
women and children took to Facebook with
a photo of a casually dressed Megan
standing front and center alongside the
caption the Duchess of Sussex Megan
Markel visited us today to discuss
issues affecting women in the community
as for Harry's whereabouts well a source
tells ET he isn't returning to Canada to
be with Megan and Archie right away
quote the Duke has some meetings in
London early next week the 38 year old
Royals visit comes the day after her
hubby Prince Harry met with the Queen
Prince Charles and Prince William to
discuss their future within the British
monarchy Megan was originally expected
to call in but a royal source tells ET
that in the end the Sussex is decided
that it wasn't necessary for her to join
meanwhile things are heating up in the
Duchess's court case against the male as
her father Thomas Markel reportedly
could be called to testify against the
Sussex is in the lawsuit Megan filed
against the outlet and its parent
company associated papers after
publishing a letter she wrote to her
father in August 2000 18 according to
one report documents filed as the High
Court in London show the newspaper plans
to rely on evidence from Thomas Markel
stating that he had a weighty right to
tell his version of what had happened
between himself and his daughter
including the contents of the letter we
need to do is focus focus on on being
real and focus on thing the people that
we are and standing up for what we
believe in and speaking of things
the Royals believe in
in 2022 the Invictus games will travel
to a new country despite announcing last
week that he and Megan were stepping
back as senior members of the royal
family and seeking financial
independence the Duke of Sussex dropped
this news on Wednesday the Invictus
games düsseldorf 2022 the story
continues like Harry and Megan said in
their statement the plan is to continue
honoring their duty to the Queen the
commonwealth and their patronage 'as the
Invictus games falls into the last
category for Harry it's also a passion
project for him after serving 10 years
in the Armed Forces in fact a source
tells ET that the Sussex is actually
want to be able to earn a living similar
to when Harry was in the military adding
that he felt great fulfilment in his
military career it's very easy to to
completely forget about Who I am when
I'm in the Army I am one of the guys I
don't get treated any differently
according to the Queen's statement after
Tuesday's family meeting final decisions
about what the Sussex is future and
finances will look like are expected to
be reached in the coming days in the
meantime it's business as usual for
Harry's big brother Prince William
the Duke of Cambridge stepped out with
his wife Kate Middleton at City Hall in
Bradford England on Wednesday for their
first joint event since Megson
gait wowed in a black and white Zara
dress with an olive green Alexander
McQueen coat and black heels as they
greeted fans and accepted flowers and
kind words according to royal reporters
William politely ignored any questions
about his brother and sister-in-law
after City Hall the duo made a surprise
visit at the my Lahore restaurant which
was inspired by the city of Lahore in
Pakistan a place the Cambridge's visited
on their royal tour of the country last
fall william and kate's final stop was
at the UK women's Muslim Council
[Music]